yeah hugely difficult for everybody and
when you get a cancer diagnosis it's bad
enough but if you get a cancer diagnosis
that's stage four that's incurable
you're never cured your chances of
living beyond two years are 25 at best
uh luckily I'm just beating that and
luckily Deborah James beat That by a lot
she was diagnosed and lived for five
years but only because of a new drug
that she was on track she was in a trial
and and it worked really well for her
and then of course it stopped working
and that's when she was in real trouble
now when I was diagnosed I was I was
devastated you know the whole bottom
fell out of my world and and the world
of my family and I just thought who's
the person I can talk to to get some
advice on how to deal with this
um and and she was the first person that
I thought of we've met a function
um about a year before we got on like a
house on fire very similar in many ways
and the fact that she had lived with
stage four cancer for such a long time
and with such a smile on her face and
you know dancing her way through chemo
and running marathons and looking
amazing and being you know Ambassador
for Sweaty Betty and you know all of
that just made me think
I want to be like that I want to deal
with it the way that she has dealt with
it so we had a long phone call and I
just said how do you how do you live
with this bird and it's such a massive
massive burden to carry this this death
Cloud hanging over you that you are
probably going to die before everybody
else before all your friends and um she
said you don't you you don't you don't
no you don't deal with it you don't ever
get over it but you just learn to
incorporate it into your life and you
learn to incorporate all the treatments
into your life it just becomes part of
your life and part of your journey and
we chatted for ages and she just said
all you need is options Jackie that's
all you need and um and she had options
I've got options and then she ran out of
options and it's just such a terrible
shame because she was a great Ambassador
for people with stage four cancer how do
you live with that and she definitely
lived life to the full with that